[Music]
hey everyone Mike McCarty here with 70
hours of Assassin's Creed Odyssey in the
bag Odyssey is largely based around its
progression and more specifically its
loot as such one of the joys of the game
is finding the best legendary gear to
outfit your mercenary with so without
further ado here are three of my
personal favorite legendary sets along
with an overview of where you'll find
them to help you through those tougher
late-game quests as a side note we're
avoiding story spoilers but if you don't
want to see any of the gear before you
pick it up obviously don't watch this
video first off is the Spartan war hero
armor this one is pretty straightforward
with all five pieces equipped Cassandra
or Alexios will get a 15% damage boost
with their warrior abilities these
include the bulrush shield breaker your
over power attacks and of course the
infamous Sparta kick
all-in-all this set is great for open
combat to get this set you'll have to
kill every one of the cultists in the
peloponnesian league branch for spoiler
purposes we won't show the cultists tree
here but you'll come across several of
the members throughout the main
storyline and outside of that just
follow the clues next up is the pirate
armor this loadout will mainly benefit a
stealthy approach and because of this
it's one of my favourite legendaries in
the game it gives you a 15% damage
increase to every assassin ability this
includes basic assassinations with your
broken spear critical assassinations the
teleportation rush assassination and the
debilitating hero strike ability which
if you're not using you should try it
out if your broken spear is your weapon
of choice and you prefer to stay silent
whenever possible this set should
definitely be a go-to you learn these
five pieces by killing each cultists in
the gods of the Aegean Sea branch almost
all of these will be found on the open
ocean as pirates themselves so make sure
you're putting the resources into the
necessary upgrades with your ship via
trusty ax in order to take them down
third but definitely not least is the
Amazon set
this is one of the more useful
Legendary's in the game as it refills
your health bar by doing any type of
damage from archery abilities to basic
dagger at them as long as you get enough
attacks in and make the effort to stay
on the offensive the Amazon Set will let
you take down enemies three or in a few
of my cases four levels above your
mercenary this could help you take down
cult members or clear a high-level
athenian fort to get the full set just
kill every cultist in the heroes of the
cult branch so there you have it our
three favorite legendary armor sets from
assassin's creed Odyssey these aren't
the only ones of course there are about
a dozen more each with their own
abilities and buffs and aesthetic values
make sure to let us know your favorites
and you can go over to GameSpot to see a
longer gallery that covers more of the
legendary sets in the meantime stay
tuned to game spot because we'll be
covering Assassin's Creed Odyssey in the
coming weeks
[Music]